today marks 50 years since the start of
riots at the Stonewall Inn in New York
City police raid led to a backlash that
fueled a modern-day gay rights movement
CTM lead national correspondent that's
David beg know is that the Stonewall Inn
with the story of two men who witnessed
that raid and the clashes that followed
David good morning - Gail good morning
to you it happened in 1969 and you know
who did it the NYPD's public morals
squad that was the thing back then they
raided the bar but gay bars were
commonly rated during that time period
what happened that was different was as
the patrons were kicked out onto the
street they started to fight back they
picked up everything they could on the
street and just started throwing it at
the bar and that led to the movement
which spread nationally there was a
bartender who was there that night still
works in the bar today we start our
story with him he calls himself tree
Sequoia he was a 30 year old bartender
when police raided the stonewall we knew
it was another raid when I was thought
we heard a crash and somebody to Iraq
with the window but this time Stonewall
patrons resisted arrest the violence
escalated and eventually hundreds of
people joined in mark Segal was there
too Stonewall turned him into an
activist from very first day it was
we're going to take back our identity
we're no longer going to allow society
to label us will be out loud and proud
and in your face in 1973
Segal stormed a live broadcast the CBS
Evening News with Walter Cronkite held a
sign saying gays protest CBS Prejudice a
message seen by millions of viewers but
Cronkite heard his message
homosexual men and women have organized
to fight for acceptance and
respectability months later CBS became
one of the first networks to discuss gay
rights just recently the NYPD
Commissioner James O'Neal apologized to
the gay community the actions in the
laws with the discriminatory and
oppressive do you remember where you
were when you decided I have to do this
I wasn't sure I was going to do it until
I got up to the podium quite frankly I
said you know this is this has to be
done otherwise New York City is not
going to be the place that it needs to
be despite the progress made since the
riots
statistics show that tolerance for LGBTQ
Americans particularly among young
people has sharply decreased from 63% in
2016 to 45% last year Sarah Kate Ellis
is president of GLAAD one of the
nation's leading gay rights advocacy
organizations finish this for me our
story today is is about joining forces
with all marginalized people since
Stonewall pride has been a lookingglass
for 28 year-old Raymond Braun the
Stonewall riots are history
but it's an event that motivated him to
travel around the country to places like
Tuscaloosa Alabama a city that held its
first gay pride parade in 2014 a journey
documented in the film state of pride we
should be thinking about prides in
literally every community even if 20
people show up it's a couple rainbow
flags in a picnic table that's important
you can't legislate acceptance if you
are not accepted you are not safe and
you are not gonna move through this
world with the same rights no matter
what as anybody else
our stories are our most powerful tools
for building acceptance
you know in 2016 President Obama
declared the Stonewall Inn a National
Monument
so the gay pride march here in New York
City happens on Sunday and it coincides
with world Pride more than two and a
half million people are expected Tony I
will leave you with this mark Segal who
you saw in the story who interrupted
Walter Cronkite's newscast said to me
this week when I interviewed him he said
David if you remember nothing else
remember this pride means visibility
David thank you very much and you can
hear more of David's conversation with
mark Segal about Stonewall 50 years ago
on today's CBS this morning podcast you
can listen wherever you like to get your
podcast if there was ever proof that
history doesn't move in a straight line
it's the fact that months after
stonewall the bar became a juice bar and
then a bagel shop then a Chinese
restaurant then a shoe store now it's a
national monument and open again at the
bar yeah I don't want to miss the words
that he said I like that pride means
visibility and what the woman and the
piece that if you are not accepted you
are not saved yeah very important you
can't legislate acceptance absolutely
true yet so you have to change minds and
by the way you couldn't get in the
studio today in protest because we got
security don't give anybody any ideas